what's goodie hot breath verse welcome
back to hot breath
that is my host guinness i am your
co-host comedian joel byers and our
mission here at hop breath
is to cultivate the next generation of
great comics and we are doing that
in this type 5 series where we're
sharing quick tips
about how you can create a tight five
minute set ready for bookers
so today's video has three quick tips
and a bonus
at the end telling you how to actually
contact bookers in a way that they'll
want to book you
so let's get to it first up
the number one thing bookers are looking
for is are you funny
are you performing a set that is making
an audience laugh
like it or not as comedians we are a
product
we are being hired to provide the
service
of laughter to the audience so the
bookers
can sell chicken wings i've interviewed
several club owners
on my podcast and some of them had said
comedy clubs are really just a
restaurant with a stage
so that being said you want to be able
to provide the service of
laughter to their customer so
they want to make sure your set is funny
now tip number two
as some of you may be thinking oh but
funny is subjective
and you know my ironic mustache from
flannel shirt
it's not funny to most people but it is
funny to the four comics in the back of
the room that look just like me
i hear you out there joseph brad
chad whatever your name is
i hear you and speaking of that they're
looking to make sure you're also not
a hack they're making sure you're not
just recycling material
that you may be read on a meme somewhere
or that you may be read on a bathroom
wall
somewhere at a venue that you weren't
booked at but they're begging for stage
time
yeah you know who you are so
are you a hack is your material unique
to you
or is this just kind of recycled
material that
really anyone could do that they've
heard before you're doing street jokes
you're reading
popsicle sticks and snapple caps are you
doing that kind of material if you are
that could be a red flag to bookers so
thirdly
the material they're looking for is that
personal material
is that unique material i can tell you
from interviewing
so many bookers and late night bookers
specifically
is that they are looking for you
the comedian they're looking to learn
from you as a booker
especially late night they're looking
for a set
that they could write a sitcom about so
when you're doing a tight five-minute
set you want to pitch to bookers
you want to make sure you're doing a set
where it's personal it's unique to you
and you should be doing this anyway
writing material that's unique to you i
always put my comedy
through the filter of could someone else
say this
joke and it be just as funny if that's
the case
then i get rid of it i i kill the joke
it's not worth it
write in that personal material because
that's how you're going to find your
voice faster as well
a great quick way to find your voice is
to do personal material
do material that's unique to you your
own unique experiences your own unique
points of view your own unique opinions
all of those will help you to find your
voice
and find the bookers that want a book
comedian
oh that was a good tip if you found that
tip helpful go ahead and hit that
subscribe button
so more comments can find these tips now
the bonus tip here
as we're landing the plane and running
running low on time here
the bonus tip on how to actually contact
bookers
this is so simple
and overlooked in comedy and i can tell
you i've booked several shows and i've
interviewed a bunch of bookers
be professional when you contact a
booker
don't say yo hey here's uh
a link let me get some stage time be
professional
hey so and so i've heard great things
about your club i've heard great things
about your show
i'm comedian blank i have this
experience
i would love the opportunity to perform
on your show
at a date you see me a good fit for
below is a link
to my tight five minute set
i hope to hear from you soon thank you
boom just a nice professional email and
make sure the video
is you know of quality make sure you're
not shooting it on your android
you know make sure it's a good quality
video as best as it can be i've heard
bookers say the gambit of
you know i interviewed the book at the
laughing school and he's like i've seen
some terrible sets in 4k
so they're not necessarily like oh this
needs to be a multi-cam
shoot but they need to be able to see
you and hear you at least see your
facial expressions how you performing be
able to hear
your jokes clearly so they know what
kind of comic they're trying to book
here
so those are just a few quick tips if
you'd like to learn more about how you
can develop your type 5 minute set
join our free facebook group where i'll
be in there hanging out with other
comics around the world
all helping each other level up their
comedy together
we're all in this together comics and
guinness
and we will see you on the other side my
friends
subscribe bye